well now the uh leader of the brexit
party nigel farage has expressed
skepticism about that brexit deal
negotiated by the prime minister just
announced by the prime minister
mr price says the deal would keep the uk
far too closely aligned with the
european union the former member of the
european parliament also
says uh he hopes this would be the
beginning
of the end of the european union
well uh let's hear it from him himself
uh mr fraz joins me now
very good to talk to you and uh happy
christmas to you is this the
the kind of christmas present you wanted
from the prime minister i'm guessing
from what i said there
it's not oh look i'm saying it's not
perfect and i'm worried that we're going
to be too closely aligned to eu rules
and
indeed you know that's what the eu
bosses are saying um that we
will not be able to step out of line uh
without them having the threat of
imposing immediate tariffs but look
that detail we'll discover in the next
couple of days
all right what i did think was good news
was when barney has said
that the british have made no
commitments on foreign policy or defense
that sounded like really quite good
progress
and if we take the big picture you know
and don't forget i've been campaigning
for us to leave for 30 years and this is
may not be perfect but it's a very very
big day
and a big step forward so look overall
of course of course i've got concern
over areas
but is this progress are we far better
off than we were five years ago
absolutely if you're an mp would you
vote for it
uh well i'd need to see the detail and i
would not want to be bounced
into voting for it in a couple of days
having not read it so i think what
parliament should do
is have a vote in principle and then in
the new year
go through it in detail in principle
given where we are right now given that
this has been the most divisive issue in
british politics for three decades
if this brings some peace and some
stability
then yes in principle i would okay uh
but what do you think
i want to ask you about the the prime
minister's language there about the
continuing connections with the european
union uh when he talks i mean
obviously he's used this language an
awful lot our eu partners and friends we
know that
but about being culturally emotionally
historically and strategically
attached to europe and that uh
we remain uh collaborative with uh the
eu over
issues like science and he also said our
basic goals
remain the same yeah i just shook my
head
i don't i don't agree at all i think we
actually have a much closer cultural
affinity
with many parts of the english-speaking
world than we do with continental europe
and
and that's one of the reasons of course
in the end that we voted for brexit
um you know boris does his pc bit um
plays up the pro-european side of things
he of course himself until the
referendum came along
had always been a supporter of the
european project but look
the truth of it is whatever he said
there and you know i'd also question
what he said about the fact
that we've got a canada style deal we
haven't um
you know you have to take what boris
says with a pinch of salt i think the
truth of it is
that the european union itself is
divided from north to south by a
currency
that doesn't work for the south at all
divided east to west culturally are we
seeing
you know the eu budget being vetoed and
countries like poland and hungary
very unhappy and i think in the broader
picture brexit is the beginning of the
end of the european union
i'm pro-european i'm pro-europe of
sovereign states
trading and being friends not being run
from brussels
but why does that matter to you that uh
i mean it still seems the project goes
on there you want to see the
disintegration of the
the european union you know the uk is
out you got what you wanted let the eu
do what the eu's going to do
no i don't agree i spent 20 years over
there um
and i saw the the the undemocratic
nature
of the way this project is run the fact
that it benefits big multinational
businesses
and damages all the small men and women
trying to do their best
and as history teaches us you know when
europe is happy and settled
it makes our lives easier too and all i
can see
is conflict building up north south east
and west with
within a european union uh that frankly
just wants to build this modern day
empire with an absence of democracy so
no it does matter to us
what happened i'm just thinking though
mr farage if you want to start a global
campaign
against tyranny empire building and lack
of democracy is the
the european union the most egregious
example what about the chinese
i couldn't agree more i couldn't agree
more the chinese are far
worse than anything we see in brussels
it's an utterly monstrous regime
um uh it of course uh has brought us
covid
and did its best to cover it up um and
yes
and and i'm worried about that because
you know
boris johnson declares himself to be a
synophile the only western world leader
really standing up to china was donald
trump
and if indeed joe biden comes into the
white house well the chinese communist
party are getting a bit of a free pass
okay this is a wide-ranging interview i
want to get let's get back then
to the deal what prime minister has been
saying about the european union we
haven't got the details as we've been
discussing
uh fully about the deal but what we do
know is uh let me put these two there's
a
another transition period when it comes
to fishing five and a half years
for the eu to adapt and then then
renegotiations over
over the quotas independent third party
arbitration when it comes to disputes
about things like subsidies and
and level playing fields i mean it still
seems like uh
the uk is going to remain pretty much
bound by the eu's rules
well that's the biggest worry i've got
you know we haven't yet seen the detail
on what this arbitration committee is um
i guess they're using that phrase
because we didn't want to hear the ecj
you know was the final arbiter um look
yeah you know
there are two big problems that i have
with this i want to see the detail the
first
you're quite right if we're going to
stay aligned to eu rules
and dare not step out of line because
they have the sword of damocles
hanging over us that if we become too
competitive they'll slap tariffs on well
that would be a huge disappointment
and on fisheries i mean you know to say
to the british industry
it'll be 10 years 10 years
after the country voted brexit before
we're even catching two-thirds of the
fish
in our waters isn't a good deal um
and you know for example i mean next
year
and british boats in devil and cornwall
land bluefin tuna yes or no
i don't know the answers to that i'm
hoping we'll get some detail over the
course of the next few days but the
fishing industry
the coastal communities today are
disappointed northern ireland
today is of course extremely
disappointed
uh those of us who want britain to
become competitive and global
a concern over what those level playing
for
provisions mean and and i share all of
those concerns
but the point i'm making is that on the
31st of january this year
and the first of january 2021 we've made
the big
historic break the brexit wars are over
and there's no going back and i will at
least celebrate that this evening
and and is that the main benefit from
your point of view this the sovereignty
argument the
the emotional side of it the the end of
the the brexit wars the end of the
relationship because a lot of people and
a lot of the debate during
the referendum campaign was about the
economic benefits when
and if do you think they will flow well
you know what when it comes to economics
you can get two experts on a panel one
i'll tell you will be poorer
one will tell you we could be a lot
richer and they both could be wrong
what is beyond doubt is that with brexit
we get back something that we used to
think was rather valuable and it's
called democracy
and it means that you can actually vote
for people that make your laws
and then vote the people who want to get
rid of them and the biggest problem with
the european union
was any single piece of eu law that came
into british law
there was nothing the electors could do
in a general election or a parliament
could do
even if all 650 of them voted against it
we
literally given away the ability to
govern ourselves
and brexit makes us a free country it
makes us a democratic country
it doesn't by the way mean we'll get
everything right
but it does at least mean we'll make our
own successes
and our own failures in the future ah
well i wanted to ask you about that on
the economic front because you know it's
kind of been
polarized into singapore on 10 singapore
on sea
or staying very much like the eu
a bigger role for the state huge
investment in public services and
following rules
and regulations i mean do you tend
towards if i may term it that the
singapore
model cutting the red tape cutting the
taxes encouraging the investment
of course i think you know i mean the
whole idea of the european single market
the whole idea of a level playing field
is
anti-competitive and big state in its
very nature
and it makes it much more difficult for
smaller medium-sized competitors
to break into industries that are run by
a handful of big companies
so for me the economic vision of brexit
well number one it was global
because you know let's face it the
eurozone
is only 15 of the world's gdp and it
goes down one percent every year so the
future
for traders are going to be outside
europe um but i want us to be
on tax on regulation employment
legislation environmental law
i think we can legislate smarter and
better and make this country
far more competitive you know than
germany or france and elsewhere and if
we get that right
then you know the thought of singapore
is that we get money
you know hundreds of billions flooding
into britain
from all over the world and so the
biggest concern
economically is just how closely tied
are we going to be to those european
rules and what's the arbitration process
going to be
and if if we have signed up to something
that stops us from having the option of
being singapore
that will be a great shame okay always
good talking to you mr farage
nigel ferrari thank you very much indeed